this time on life links a reporter's
meet young people held back by borders
and walls border lines is this x hashtag
gonna meets a Mexican banned from the
United States despite his service in the
US Marines in the West Bank yelda meets
a woman confronted with a militarized
border right on her doorstep and Joel
accompanies a Syrian refugee on his
arduous journey into the European Union
as germany celebrates 25 years of
reunification walls continue to divide
use a hashtag to join the conversation
barricade soldiers and checkpoints they
don't just separate the Palestinian
territories from Israel here in the West
Bank they also split the city of Hebron
is it okay apparently it's not I'm with
Saunders a Palestinian student who lives
on the other side of this checkpoint
right by a Jewish settlement we know the
rules more than you we know okay what do
you live there well we go straight then
left I've done it is your friend yeah
you want to go to your home yeah to my
house before we do something we tell the
caramel in the bus is everything okay
but you see we have guns we have guns we
have guns here till you have a gun and
you know no big whatever just tell me
what the problem is
like why wouldn't you want me to know
their security reason the soldiers are
here to protect Israeli settlers from
attacks and from us too I guess is ok no
excuse me it's not my job to call them
attack or to call anyone from Israeli
government ok you want your friends to
go there sometimes you have to do
something he's the commander he can't do
something that's not my business a fun
job search ok you want me to pass the
phone to the commander who told me to
call you I don't know who is I think I
think it's like I don't know if it's big
save me speaks Hebrew there is
assessment and they for me I have the
permission to go there and anyone at you
know I have a lot of faith visitor they
came from there they pass from this kid
and it was not problems there is no
problem for special journalists as
international it's not it's allowed to
them to to be anywhere they want so a
little lips like Karen all so why do you
think it
this is I don't know some soldiers
really it depends to their moods some
soldiers they said okay it's it's our
job we have to do it I still don't know
so what did he say who was that now he's
from them attack ok dem attack is
responsible for the communication
between us and the Palestinian basically
there was a misunderstanding no comment
so we good to go now yes you can go I'm
sorry from the unconvinced and
everything but you know the procedure is
is complicated
this border is not disputed it's here to
keep foreigners out Border Patrol's
detained almost half a million people
last year alone here at the southern
edge of the United States
on weekends US border guards open up
what's called friendship park here
family and friends on both sides of the
border are reunited well sort of so
Mexicans living in the US illegally can
see their loved ones i'm here to see
daniel who wants to come to the US but
can't so I'm actually not allowed to
talk to Daniel across the border for
security reasons so me crossing the
fence is no problem it's a quick drive
from California down to Tijuana in
northern Mexico that's where Daniels
been living for the past four years his
parents brother and sister are four of
the twelve million people who live in
the u.s. undocumented he lived there too
for 10 years before he had to go and
just looking at that border I mean it
doesn't make you feel angry angry no
kind of smooth like sad you know like I
just want to jump up run over and go
home but I can't and you could I mean
some people do that yeah but then what
you know I would still be stuck in a
place where I couldn't go to work I
couldn't go to school I couldn't have a
life like I wanted to so yeah you could
just jump the border and be over there
and
big fruit and vegetables for eight hours
an hour I mean it's not it's not it's
not as easy or as comfortable as most
people think other moments when you
seriously consider doing it yeah of
course my mother just survived cancer
and at some point she was really sick
and for a moment there I thought she
wasn't gonna make it so i was planning
of crossing the desert illegally into
united states just like to see my mother
Daniel didn't just live in the u.s. he
risked his life in battle for the US as
a marine in iraq but when they found out
he wasn't a US citizen they kicked him
out the military we have the same of no
man left behind well they're leaving us
behind you know they're there there's
they're making it so our service it's
not good enough just because we had the
bad luck of not living not being born in
the United States I mean we we're not
just illegals who have been deported we
are and we will always be at heart
Americans who have been banished you
know who have been left out from the one
place that we love
in the past months this has become one
of the most infamous borders in the
world it's part of the route taken by
refugees trying to get into the European
Union I came here to cross the border
with them just two weeks before Hungary
shut it completely I was among the last
of tens of thousands who snuck under the
razor wire or crossed into the EU on
these railroad tracks
my journey begins in Belgrade the
capital of Serbia looking for someone
willing to take me along on their trip
Serbia grants migrants 72 hours of legal
residency and that makes Belgrade a
crucial resting spot
rumors were rampant about police dragnet
and thieves at the border but despite
the risks a young Syrian engineer named
Sammy agreed to bring me along nowadays
it's very hard a 2p in Syria it's our
country I hope that maybe I kiss the
ground yeah and I hope that
yeah we can't find the solution yam for
this big problem what was like the
moment that you thought okay it's time
to go to Germany I need to make this
trip yeah when did you decide this
decision because I have to in all things
my living and in my home with my friends
I have to finish I have to finish my
work very hard decision to stop all
things and go in this young dark dark
way yeah it's a very very tough
situation it's good to be safe here in
bankrupt good yeah like it's been three
weeks since Sami and his friends left
the Middle East now we're waiting for a
bus to take us closer to the next border
hungry for Sami and thousands of others
it's their point of entry into the EU we
are pleased now to walk in this but
because no countries want Syrians to
come and why nothing is really really
honest to be fear from Syrians nothing
whatever
samee wants to cross the border at night
he's hoping we can avoid a run-in with
the police
in this Jewish Israeli settlement in
Hebron avoidance is the name of the game
no one has a problem with me using the
roads but sunders who lives here isn't
allowed to because she's Palestinian
this is the path she takes to get home
today to Israeli acquaintances are
visiting from Tel Aviv besides the
settlers not many Jewish Israelis come
here for the guests it's a two-hour
drive into an unfamiliar world so these
are actually doing yeah here's the
settlement yes son desses neighbor is a
well-known right-wing nationalist
politician conflict here seems pretty
much unavoidable first time he throw
stones and we were here I second time I
was here and I took this one here a
certain we were there but day and he was
here so he throws stones there but no
one liked enjoy here in Jordan do you
appreciate Israeli people coming over
here yeah it's really nice because it's
completely different between Israelis
and Israeli settlers be careful because
yours is it's not like these people you
know do you think that by building up
the wall the separation wall between
between the two sides are in line yeah
does that make it worse the world is
there because before that there was you
know a suicide bomber every every other
month I just think that this is good for
putting out a fire but it's not it's far
from being a long-term solution it's
only you know aggregating bitterness and
an anger and you know no no wonder we
are you know experiencing what we are
experiencing
sundus gives tours to visitors from
other countries telling them her side of
the story a story of the ongoing
struggle between Palestinians and
settlers where tensions regularly end in
violence perpetrated by both sides
settler woman she catched my brother it
took a big stone and she tried to to put
the stone inside his mouth but luckily
he closed his geez and she only crushed
in his teeth which is like gay soldiers
ready soldiers game and so what happened
and they saw exactly what the sizzler
woman makes to my brother luckily the
when it to the curt happened the soldier
told eight of the court the truth do you
think there's anything that we can do as
like people from Europe I was in Europe
and I sometimes I I heard from a lot of
people like they ask me where I'm from
so I said Palestine so they say but
where's Palestine so this is really big
problem for me and it's really hard the
22 year old act as a kind of ambassador
whether or not she even has a country
yeah so nothing has helium a be nothing
about sami shows me how we'll walk along
the railroad tracks and sneak through
the farms it's one of the last open
routes across the border we may be here
or something like this after them the
just the wall we go in corn bottoms are
you feeling okay right now or is it
pretty
yeah a little bit worried yeah but I
believe in God so
may God protect us it's around 11pm and
we're now closer to one of the toughest
borders on Sammy's journey we have two
options walk or take a taxi the driver
wants 50 euros to take us five
kilometers it's a ripoff but it's
nothing compared to the thousands Sami
already spent to make it this far and to
what will encounter later but yeah so
what's the plan weakness the border yeah
without any sounds cigarettes and phones
light then we will turn of all things
just keep walking yeah
and we don't know what maybe will it
will move me we see it but yeah I will
go and where are you going to go with
this whole the whole group altogether
yeah the whole group because we are
worried about that maybe anyone can
install our money so we have to be in
groups and we can protect ourselves to
reach the final station house hunt ABC
hora y ella koon yourself to come hurry
I person yeah okay okay yeah hurry up
please together there yeah please hurry
organize yourself it's group 5 [ __ ] out
yeah yeah because no bus no bus until
tomorrow eight o clock okay
police on the Serbian side don't even
try to stop us they seem happy with the
cash they're getting from the taxis I'm
gonna shove it i guess i miss tisha okay
are we done yeah I think Kelly whatta ya
between yeah yeah both of us because
people talking is very overcrowded yeah
yeah in this new development
just keep walking and if you see any
police we don't they look at this cake
how far do we have to walk with us
tonight in the gondola I don't fight
through the mattress
we are worried about you look at tara's
on something like a war here is really
more yeah we don't know he rather police
cars and helicopters everywhere
no viennois happened there
it's been four years since Daniel ended
up what he sees as the wrong side of the
border he sat to build a new life in
Mexico find new friends and figure out
how to make ends meet the 29 year old
lives with his grandma here in Tijuana
his old hometown hey that's what their
friends come with their friend yeah
musical no no yes putting away the past
hasn't been easy for Daniel once a
marine always a Marine of course to
enlist Daniel claimed he had US
citizenship the marine corpse turned a
blind eye you lied when when you
enlisted yeah were you aware of that
yeah i mean i knew i wasn't born in
united states uh but it was the only way
to enlist and had the opportunity to
serve the country that i was living in
you know there's always when you grow up
I was the mexican United States saw was
the Cystic my love taking our jobs or
they're just feeding off the system hey
I didn't want to be another Mexican
United States I wanted to be able to say
hey you know what I did something I
served this country and I was one to put
my life on the line for it
after he got kicked out of the Marines
Daniel face deportation he chose to
leave voluntarily instead yeah come on
now phone calls are the closest he can
get to his family there are 1.3 million
people living in Tijuana but like Daniel
many of them don't want to be here
they're waiting for the chance to make
it to the States some have already lived
there been deported and are hoping to
get back
Daniel thought he could build a future
here he started University next year
he'll finish his degree in law but over
the past four years his hopes about
living in this country have faded now he
can't imagine stone the thing is that
when i got here to Mexico I I didn't
realize how American I was until I get
Mexico you know and that's when it hit
me that I don't identify with the
culture I don't identify with the people
i don't identify with with its
government with political system with
the way thing they do things
sundus identifies very much with her
culture although sometimes she prefer
not to wear her headscarf but the people
in the Arab part of Hebron are quite
conservative nonetheless she'd rather
live there than in the Jewish settlement
but that's not an option for her family
the house where they live belongs to
relatives and they don't want to leave
it to settlers she wants to show me
around her bronze ancient city center to
get there we have to go through another
checkpoint one of around 20 here Sanders
passes through them several times a day
on her way to university to the shops
whenever she wants to go anywhere
200,000 people live in Hebron making it
the biggest city in the West Bank it's
also the only one with Jewish
settlements at the center of town this
place the tomb of Abraham makes it a
holy city for both Jews and Muslims
thousands of Israeli soldiers are
stationed here to protect around 600
Jewish settlers unrest here is
commonplace the city is witnessed two
attacks riots and murders on both sides
some incredibly heinous acts the posting
and Buddhist fence also to protect
themselves from settlers stones of
course it doesn't it doesn't take them
from dirty water and also they threw
like a chemical water yeah
this was once the busiest Street in the
city that's before it was blocked off
for the settlers and more than 1,800
Palestinian shops were shut down sundus
isn't allowed to come here but I am and
I want to talk to the settlers no I
don't know English no can you know for
doing Mozilla no you don't speak English
no
finally the student from a religious
school agrees to talk to me we have to
take our guns with us they have taken
with you yes lies because it's a
dangerous look I believe that the these
countries it's our country 4,000 years I
believe that God gave it gave it to a
rom it's ours have you also heard of
settlers attacking Palestinians we know
New York since there are some naruto you
know if some Palestinian stuck me so I
defends myself but we don't we don't
fight them at all you think they want to
see you think they want peace I think
it's complicated sadly the longer I'm
here and the more i talk to people on
both sides the less hope i have that
this conflict will ever end
the hours dragged on and Sami and I make
our way down the tracks toward hungry a
man appears out of the darkness and
offers to take us safely across for a
hundred euros each we don't pay but the
experience cultivates our confusion and
fear we crouched at every sound and
pause to debate the route amidst the
tension eventually we reach the border
guarded by a single police car
wait
those who stay on the tracks end up at
this makeshift police camp buses are
running here around the clock to take
them on to bigger camps go back please
go back instead we cut through
cornfields toward a gas station a black
market has developed here with people
offering to get us to Budapest for a
hefty fee it's a scary scene of mobsters
and profiteers stoking fears to get
higher rates
he's comatose to close the other as we
drive away the first thing sami does is
call his family
listen
they are waiting for any news
think not me happy that identity yeah of
course as they are i think they are
proud of me i'm ready to complete my
very bad trip yeah
there were there were definitely there
were definitely some moments
that were tense he of course and all my
life okay which is okay
I think more puffy now that we're in
Budapest instead of another expensive
taxi ride we're getting to the hotel by
foot
Tijuana is a city of broken dreams every
day here people climb over the fence
lots of them get picked up and are sent
right back to Mexico
last year u.s. Border Patrol stopped
almost half a million people on the
other side of the fence most of them
Mexicans and that same time the u.s.
deported almost a hundred and eighty
thousand Mexicans
deported US soldiers in Tijuana come
here to Hector Barajas himself a u.s.
veteran who's also trying to help Daniel
out Daniel's cases a little is a little
unique because he was undocumented but
most of us served legally we were in the
United States legally we were drafted
into combat in the Vietnam War so these
were people that put their life on the
line for the American government why for
example your own case or like most
people why are they important the
majority of the veterans that are being
deported committed some type of crime
after they were in the military war
while in the military but the majority
after so we got out served in
Afghanistan and the gulf war with
honorable discharges after the military
because a lot of the men are suffering
from post-traumatic syndrome they come
back from the war they don't know how to
cope with it they start drinking they
might start using then in order to to
keep that habit they might rob somebody
or rob steal something and then family
go to jail they get deported Hector and
others in his position feel they've been
given double punishment first thrown in
jail then sent packing there are no
official figures on how many US veterans
have been deported but Hector says has
got to be more than 3,000 so so I have
some good news for you and this is a an
email from the USA clu and you know this
is not a hundred percent but this is
what I have have you spoken to the
individual who you mentioned had falsely
claimed US citizenship on his
application for the military it does not
appear that did that that would bar is
naturalization and basically to put you
in contact with its own you might go
home building perfect perfect that's
what that's not harder yeah that's what
I needed me and there's some lawyer to
look at it come on yeah and that old
that'll turn this nightmare you know so
perfect I don't know it's too much like
I'm I'm excited I just I want to I don't
want to like jinx aight i don't want to
get my hopes up i just wanted to do it
one step at a time and hopefully he
works out and I i get to get home
definitely that's what I want
American coca-cola
just looking at Daniel you'd hardly know
it's the news he's been hoping to hear
for years he's probably just too afraid
of getting his hopes up in case it
doesn't work out I didn't choose to come
to United States but he's a place that I
fell in love with and I now call my home
and all those mistakes that has made in
the past I just hope I don't have to pay
for them for the rest of my life
while thousands of refugees are taking
to the streets Sami is hiding out in
this rundown hotel police are here
checking people's papers and making
arrests clearly they've heard they're
undocumented migrants Sammy's hotel is
even charging refugees 15 euros a night
just to sleep in the lobby Sami waits
until the coast is clear when the police
are finally gone he comes out to meet me
the 28 year old is more than a little
scared I didn't make any problem minimal
in all my life you definitely do not
seem like a guy who's making a lot of
problems I'm not smoke at all I didn't
have anyone calling all my life and I'm
drugs no tattoo know things like this
just a normal person I don't know what
my mother will feel ya if she see if she
sees this film because she will see all
this pleasure and yeah it would
definitely make my mom worried i can
tell you that much I I believe it yeah
we go shopping for the next leg of
Sammys journey little does he know he'll
be calling me from Sweden just a few
days later you're gonna go back to the
hotel yeah I think it's better the
bullies are here so maybe they are very
close so please we have to go
the wall between Israel and the West
Bank stretches more than 700 kilometers
and its construction is nowhere near
complete right behind this wall is
Jerusalem sundus has family there but to
visit them she needs special permission
and that is not easy to get do you think
it is more
would not exist anymore that would
change anything first we are under
occupation and if there's no wall
Israeli government will put more and
more checkpoints so in my opinion I
don't think so that they will change
anything I'd like to be free in my land
to go anywhere I want without any
checkpoint without any permissions but
of course with your all optimistic we
were patient also so yeah I hope so
something will change in the future Adam
change is a big word in Israel and the
West Bank where religion and politics
have created huge walls that cut through
the land and were still through people's
hearts and minds
you